UCTV, UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
TELEVISION - WWW.UCTV.TV
UC SAN DIEGO
STEM CELL PROGRAM
RESEARCH ADVANCES
RECONSTRUCTING THE BRAIN IN A DISH
EMERGENCE OF NEUROINFLAMMATION
FROM RETROTRANSPOSONS
In this work we took advantage
of a rare disorder
like Aicardi-Goutieres to really
explore the fundamental mechanism
that happens in your brain.
Clinically
you can see the manifestation
pre-birth by ultrasound.
You can detect that their brains
are not developing well.
They have microcephalic brains.
Overall, it's a very severe
neurological disorder.
DESIGNING THE STUDY AND
CHOOSING TARGETS FOR INVESTIGATION
There are a couple of things that
we knew about Aicardi-Goutieres.
One is the fact that it behaves
like an autoimmune response
in the absence
of any obvious infection.
Second is the nature
of the genetic mutations
in genes such as TREX1.
And finally, the complete absence
of an animal model,
they don't show
the neurological abnormalities
that we see in those patients.
STUDY TARGETS:
TREX1 AND LINE1 ELEMENTS
TREX1 stands for three
prime repair exonuclease 1.
Exonuclease in general,
they degrade RNA or DNA,
so the body
can defend against a virus.
So TREX1 basically
its function is to degrade DNA,
single-stranded DNA.
If you look at TREX1
inside the cells,
we see an upregulation
of repetitive regions of the genome,
including retrotransposons
such as line retrotransposons.
Line 1 elements
are repetitive sequences
that are able to move from one
region of the genome into another
by a mechanism
called retrotransposition,
and the way that they do that
is by using reverse transcriptase.
As far as we know, Line 1 elements
are active during early development
and also in the brain.
CHOOSING A METHODOLOGY:
STEM CELLS
With the absence
of a good animal model,
the only way to study this condition
in a human background
is to take advantage
of human pluripotent stem cells.
So we use IPSCs,
induced pluripotent stem cells,
and embryonic stem cells.
And you create specific mutations
and use these cells
to differentiate
specific cell lines.
Using these cell lines
we are able
to create a different model,
an organoid, that recapitulates
the process that we have
in our brain development.
MODEL FUNCTION AND OBSERVED EFFECTS
So when we engineered the cells
we confirmed
that the mutation is there
but there was no TREX1 protein
inside those cells.
In a healthy cell
you always have your DNA,
in the nucleus,
where it's supposed to be.
And so what we saw
is that outside of the nucleus
to an extreme amount,
single-stranded DNA existing.
And a lot of the DNA was actually
the Line 1 retrotransposon element.
They behaved like normal cells
with the TREX1 protein
being expressed.
The big surprise came
when we pushed or instructed
these neuro progenitor cells
to become neurons,
and we see a dramatic effect.
By a large proportion, the AGS
patient cells were just dying.
We knew then that it was
a problem of cell-death.
The TREX1 mutant cells
virtually cannot make neurons.
That strong dramatic phenotype
prompted us to make astrocytes.
And when we compare the amount
of Line retrotransposons
we realized that there were way more
in the cytoplasm
compared to controls.
What we see is that these cells
look like immunoreactive.
They feel like they were attacked
by a virus or something, we think.
They basically sense
retrotransposons as the enemy
and they trigger
this interferon response.
The astrocyte signals,
they were toxic.
So AGS patients have
intrinsic toxicity
within the neuron itself,
and extrinsic toxicity
from the astrocytes.
So they're getting hit twice.
EFFECTS ON ORGANOIDS
In the 3D system
the effects are even more dramatic.
The main thing we saw
on the AGS side
is that they were dying
as fast as they were growing.
And as a consequence
we have cerebral organoids
that looks like microcephalic.
They're smaller in size
and the amount of cell death
that we see in those neurons
is elevated
compared to the control cells.
THERAPEUTIC OPPORTUNITIES:
REVERSE TRANSCRIPTION
AND ENDOGENOUS CELL TOXICITY
Once we have these dramatic effects
we thought about a potential
therapeutic intervention.
So there are actually
reverse transcriptase drugs.
So we tried these same drugs.
When you added these retrovirals,
there was much less single-stranded
DNA in the cytocell,
and then we saw
that they were much healthier.
So they didn't have the toxicity.
They didn't have the
interferon response in astrocytes.
We completely rescued
the cell death.
Virtually they become
indistinguishable from the controls.
In the brain organoids it works
as nice as in the 2D system.
The retroviral drugs could actually
make these brain organoids
thrive as much
as in the control cells.
THERAPEUTIC OPPORTUNITIES:
CONTROLLING INTERFERON RESPONSE
Essentially
astrocytes are secreting interferons
that are killing neurons.
If you could block this pathway
you could prevent
the extrinsic cell death.
To do that we actually use a drug
that can block the
interferon receptor,
and by doing that,
we could see the same effects.
We rescue the amount
of neuronal death
that we see in the mutant cells
to a level that's comparable
to the control cells.
CONCLUSIONS
AND IMPLICATIONS OF THE STUDY
The conclusions of our work
is that we could actually
nail down the exact mechanism
both at the molecular
and the cellular level
of what's going on
during the neurodevelopment
of Aicardi-Goutieres syndrome.
So we are definitely excited
with the idea that one can design
a clinical trial
to treat Aicardi-Goutieres.
But it's also possible
that this mechanism
is more fundamental than we think,
and it might actually be working
or contributing to other diseases
such as autism, aging,
or neurodegenerative disorders
where Line elements are
highly expressed in their brains.
So it might be
more common that we think.
RECONSTRUCTING
THE BRAIN IN A DISH
EMERGENCE OF NEUROINFLAMMATION
FROM RETROTRANSPOSONS
A VIDEO SUMMARY OF
MODELING OF TREX1-DEPENDENT
AUTOIMMUNE DISEASE USING
HUMAN STEM CELLS
HIGHLIGHTS L1 ACCUMULATION
AS A SOURCE OF NEUROINFLAMMATION
PUBLISHED IN CELL STEM CELL,
AUGUST 2017
AUTHORS
THE VIEWS, CONTENTS AND OPINIONS
EXPRESSED HEREIN
DO NOT NECESSARILY REPRESENT THOSE
OF THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA